this is the weapon system the Ukrainian
President says his country needs to
fight the Russians the german-made
leopard II main battle tank seen here
during a NATO exercise in Lithuania it's
both heavier and faster than many of the
tanks Russia is using in Ukraine and
widely used by other European countries
several of whom now want to re-export
them to Kiev to end the conflict we need
to arm Ukraine so the Ukraine is able to
defend itself and Russia is not able to
push through with this agenda of
imperialism and stealing territory and
of course I would very much welcome if
Germany approves the at least licenses
or would put all own tanks for export to
Ukraine on Tuesday the polls formally
asked Germany to allow them to do just
that so far at least the German
government has not made a clear decision
as for the question on Leopard tanks
there is not yet a new position I have
always said that I'm counting on a
decision being made soon and that
remains my view the view from NATO is
clear while anti-aircraft weapons and
missiles can defend against Air Attack
and armored personnel carriers can
transport troops to the fighting the
Strategic value of heavy armor to punch
through the front lines is clear battle
tanks are of course important both to be
able to repel Russian new offensives but
also for Ukraine to be able to retake
territory to to win and to Prevail as a
sovereign independent nation in in
Europe but there is another angle to a
decision by Germany to release the
leopard twos some believe it could lead
to an escalation in the war and to a
worsening of relations between Berlin
and Moscow a Kremlin spokesperson said
on Tuesday they are already at a low
point and that is the problem facing
Olaf shots the legacy of the second
world war hangs heavy on German
governments tanks like these help the
USSR defeat Nazi Germany and yet 80
years later its modern German tanks that
might help defeat Russia in Ukraine
Dominic Kane Al Jazeera at the Soviet
War Memorial in Berlin